so I signed with three arts I remember
they got it they were like look we
understand we get that you want to write
interacts but you may just have to go in
one door at a time and I remember that's
why I signed with them because a lot of
others were still really pushing and
saying you could be the next Julia
Roberts you could be the next Sandra
Bullock and while that is really really
an incredible thing to hear it wasn't
what I knew my destiny to be and that I
really really wanted to write and direct
so at least three arts was telling me we
get your dream you may have to go in
this door to get to those two doors and
so I went with that for a while but I
never seemed to get to those two other
doors and this is around the time where
you and I was like how can they take me
seriously about being a writer director
if I'm not taking myself that seriously
how can I go out for pilot season and
work as an actress and still stand here
and say no but I really really want to
just write in direct so I had to you
know you work really really hard three
arts is very prestigious Buckwald I was
with Julia Buckwald I had worked really
hard to get to that level and I was a
working actress I did have one really
amazing mentor David Frankel which was a
game changer for me because I was still
not understanding I was like when do I
get to go to that other door the writing
and directing door David Frankel who is
a huge film director he did The Devil
Wears Prada he did Marley and me at the
time I met him so I shot that sag
experimental in 1997 it was getting me
in a lot of rooms and he was doing a TV
show at the time called grapevine which
was in 1998 and it was
shooting in Miami and so I was cast in
in the pilot of Grapevine and David
watched first and last and and I
remember we were on set and I still even
though it was really amazing to be on
set and to be an actress he watched me
kind of always migrating to the crew and
I was always standing with the crew and
I didn't really want to be and I know I
I appear to be a girl who you know I
wear makeup and I'm I might I might I'm
a feminine girl I like all that stuff
and and I'm not dishonouring acting
acting is is extraordinary and but I
wasn't passionate about it the way I was
with writing and directing and so I was
I was good but I didn't dig in and want
to really go you know I didn't I didn't
want to spend my days going to acting
classes I want it I would spend my days
riding and raising money and making my
own shorts and and if I could raise
enough money features and I remember
David and I was like where are you gonna
set up the next shot
and I remember David david frankel we
were you know it was in between shots
and he said Bethany he said I think
you're a really really great actress but
I loved your movie and you're a really
really great writer and director and I
love you being on this set but if that's
your passion you go get it and it was
the first person in this industry that
said it to me that way
you know just like someone that I truly
looked up to and admired and was
successful in the business that I wanted
to be in he was saying who you are is
enough about to cry but it's funny
because I tell people that
all the time No did you just meet about
one person who ever act ever again ever
well here's the thing so I remember him
saying that and I in it and I absorbed
every single morsel because no one had
ever truly said it to me that way and
sort of get filled me up with enough
courage because I remember sitting down
with my manager at three arts and Julia
gulia Buckwald at buck Walden associates
smells like here's the thing I
absolutely treasure and adore what all
you guys have done for me and believed
in me and have given me and right now I
have not that I was a huge actress
because I wouldn't we never commit I
would just kind of dance around it was
laughable and I enjoyed it listen to be
director to be where you got to today
that little Disney [ __ ] you did all that
for director yeah we're not having this
conversation with a car ride home we
were talking last night on the phone we
went to do an open mic at 10 o'clock at
night on the drive home when I got home
I called you and we discussed that even
if this is not what you want to do
doesn't matter you know that world now
you understand that world Bethenny as a
director is so much better than working
with an actor right because she wasn't
that size okay I don't let an actor
leave my casting room and and I've been
lucky enough to have Jeanne Bacharach as
my casting director because she knows
this if someone comes in the room and
bombs and they're nervous and I can see
they're nervous I don't let them leave
the room until all the nerves are gone
because a lot of times nerves in a room
mean that you really really really want
it and a lot of people come in and
they're terrible at auditioning but man
they were
amazing if I had been able to see them
do what they did at home before they
came so anyone that's nervous I stand up
because I remember being in those rooms
and they can feel really intimidating if
they're not talking to your looking at
you your nerves take over and for some
reason you feel a little inferior
sometimes not a little a lot I would say
that's yeah I would read and I would
take their hand and say hey guess what
my car almost ran out of gas on the way
over here I don't know how I'm gonna pay
my rent next month i just i humanised
myself and i just stand there and i was
just like i feel goofy and silly
standing here right now let's both stand
here and feel goofy and silly I cast
I've cast more people that way and they
shine you should and I love and there's
not a lot of casting I remember being
intimidated by certain casting director
I'm sorry I'm battling throat fever and
all that that's totally I was out till
3:00 in the morning doing blow and I
thought it was gonna be a regular
producers session I think yeah when I
got this the Gaza van zant was in the
room and Travolta oh my god you know
what happens to you you expect you know
they just want a [ __ ] curveball at
you yes whatever you write if you're a
young actress and insecure like I was at
that time you know oh yeah you're
reading and you could hear the line like
I'm yeah and I'm off but I would always
Center myself I would always take the
script and fold it down the middle and
even if I wasn't looking at it it was a
center for me yeah I'll never forget
being in that room there Sopranos the
second season
oh yeah thank you and what you do is I
was telling about bass ketball that one
they said the first time I asked that no
I was doing an acting class listen first
three jobs yeah I never even saw the
director that's the thing I was like
where's the director you know even when
I say I mean I'm a director it doesn't
sit in video village because a lot of
times they're sitting in video village
three rooms away from you which is fine
I'm not saying that's how I do it is the
way to do it but for me I every shot of
every movie I've ever done and for ever
my girl right now if you pulled out just
one mil just up even just one little
centimeter you'd see me because I'm as
close to my actors as I can possibly be
so that I can be there for them feed
them not feed them literally if they
need to feed them I would but literally
to be there to feed their soul to feed
what they need to help guide support
love help move pivot or just be there if
you know just just to be there that's
that's the safe haven in the bubble that
I like to create for my actors